thank you very much Jim it's good to see
I've known Jim Nussle we came in
together 16 years ago and it's it's good
to see you Jim let me tell you the
concerns that I have with your
nomination and it's not that you're not
smart and the partisanship does not
bother me i think if you stand up and
fight for what you believe in from where
I come from that's not something to be
held against people this is my concern
Jim i think the american people believe
that President Bush is increasingly out
of touch with reality in many areas and
it's not just Iraq and it really has to
do with the economy today we have heard
from Senator Gregg and others that the
economy is is really robust is a word
they use here in Washington let me ask
you this since Bush's been president
over five million people have slipped
into poverty nearly seven million
Americans have lost their health
insurance median household income has
gone down by nearly thirteen hundred
dollars three million manufacturing jobs
have been lost three million American
workers have lost their pensions home
foreclosures are now the highest on
record the personal savings rate is
below zero which hasn't happened since
the Great Depression the real earnings
of college graduates have gone down by
about five percent in the last few years
entry-level wages for male and female
high school graduates have fallen by
over three percent wages and salaries
are now at their lowest share of GDP
since nineteen twenty nine I will
concede the President Bush has done a
wonderful job for the wealthiest people
in this country and for the CEOs of
large corporations if you receive this
position very important position as head
of r1b are you prepared to go in to the
office say mr. president you have got to
represent more than the wealthiest one
percent that the middle class is
shrinking and poverty is increasing and
mr. president we need policies to
address the concerns of ordinary
Americans senator as i said to the
chairman I'm not satisfied you even
though there are statistics to show that
there's growth you pointed out a number
that show that we're that we're lacking
and
that there are people that are still not
able to succeed in our country there are
many reasons for that I'm not sure it's
can be pointed either one person or one
policy but I would concur with you that
our work is not done yet I as you
indicated some call it partisanship I
call it being passionate when you
believe in something and i have not
shrunk from that in talking either with
my colleagues but i would not shrink
from that and speaking with the
president either Jim you the president
has insisted that at a time when we have
the highest rate of childhood poverty an
issue that we don't talk enough about
but as you may know over eighteen
percent of the children in this country
live in poverty the highest rate by far
of any country on Earth the President
believes that we should completely
repeal the entire inheritance tax in a
way that applies only to the wealthiest
two-tenths of one percent if we repealed
the inheritance tax the walton family
which owns Walmart one of the wealthiest
families in America would receive over
32 billion dollars in tax breaks do you
think it's appropriate to give 32
billion dollars in tax breaks to the
wealthiest to one of the wealthiest
families in this country at the same
time when we have 9 million children
living without health insurance in this
country and the highest rate of
childhood poverty is that a good sense
of priorities in your judgment first of
all senator I any witness any nominee on
the part of an administration will most
likely represent that administration I
concede that that would be true under
the Clinton administration of the bush
no matter who the administration is the
people that they nominate need to need
to work with them we serve at the
pleasure of you know my question I know
your question and I and I and iris i
respect it because I know you and I 32
billion dollars in tax breaks for one
family and the president cuts back on
programs for our children is that make
sense to you but I also know senator
that if you if you increase the taxes on
that one family you would not solve the
problem either there's a lot of work to
be done within our tax code we just had
a
conversation about how our tax code is
not performing it's not doing the job
you think we should repeal the
inheritance tax so that one family games
32 billion dollars well not for that
purpose no sir senator but I did vote on
that behalf on that issue in the house
so I've already voted on that and my
vote was yes I will report to you as I
know you know I know I know you know I
know I know a gym this country has by
far the most unequal distribution of
income and wealth senator greg was
talking about how the wealthier paying
all of the taxes he forgot to tell us
that the top three hundred thousand
americans now earn nearly as much income
as the bottom 150 million americans
300,000 150 million the gap between the
rich and the poor is growing wider these
hedge fund guys are making more money
than you can wear any one could possibly
imagine does that growing gap between
the rich and the poor in america which
is now by far the highest in the
industrialized world concerning oh yeah
yes sir it does but i would i would say
to my friend that that my view is that
we should do everything we can to to
help the people who aren't succeeding
who are poor succeed and i don't think
that has to be done to the detriment of
people who have been successful well i
would just say that that's the line we
have heard but in reality what has
happened in the last six years is that
spread has become much wider we've been
tax breaks to billionaires and cut back
programs for the middle class and
working cuz i think mr. chairman my time
has expired